des médecins qui défilent dans la rue ce
n'est pas un spectacle courant il était
pourtant plusieurs milliers cet après
midi à paris des invalides à la gare
montparnasse 20% des cabines étaient par
ailleurs fermés à paris et près de la
moitié en province à l'origine de la
grogne des médecins le régime
conventionnel vous connaissez le
principe chaque médecin s'engage à
respecter les tarifs d'honoraires fixé
par leur syndicat et par la sécurité
sociale
or les médecins voudraient que ses
honoraires soient renégociés dans le
sens de la hausse bien sûr mais le
ministre de la santé ne l'entend pas de
cette oreille
je pense que ce qui est fait mist saint
c'est d'assister à cette démographie
galopante dans leur profession qui dans
lequel ils ont conscience qu'ils vont
être beaucoup plus nombreux d'ici
quelques années et qui peuvent crainte
ils peuvent elles peuvent craindre dans
ces conditions que la concurrence soit
difficile que certains soient amenés à
exercer dans une union des modes
d'activités qui ne soit pas aussi
satisfaisante maintenant et surtout que
compte tenu de l'impact que l'acte
médical assure ainsi claudia sociale les
pouvoirs publics soient amenés à prendre
certaines mesures non pas du tout
nationalisation mais simplement de
restriction du pouvoir d'achat car s'il
y a le double de médecins qui sont en
activité d'ici quelques années
est-ce que la sécurité sociale pourra
supporter le double dames